jedd also took to instagram recently and
said people are coming at him he wants
people to wait and and and be able to
speak out and everything what did you
think of his Instagram and what would
you say to fans sir maybe become an
actor Jen that's too easy whether what
the rumors are true or false don't come
at Jed's sister don't come at his mom
don't come out as people come at Jed
do you think Jed has some stuff to
answer to you yeah he made my girl
unhappy and so whether they're true or
false he needs to put a smile back on
his face how do you make round happen
based on what I'm seeing and hearing I
really like Jed I mean he's one of my
best friends in the house we spent a lot
of time together we were roommates every
single every time we travelled so I'm
really hoping that he finds love with
Hanna and I'm just hoping anything today
Hanna's happy because that's what this
all about
we got our final guys now what do you
think who's right for her it's down to
Tyler Peter and Jed I love Tyler and
Peter I'm really hoping she picks Jed
I like jad I think he genuinely loves
her and I think Tyler and Peter also
feel the same way but I felt like Hannah
and Jed had a connection since Rhode
Island that was unmatched for anybody
else so I'm hoping that it's authentic I
hope they kind of maintain that
connection and it works out Jed was just
a really sweet guy and you know I've
never heard him say anything bad to
anyone what about who should she end up
with who do you want Hannah to pick I
think Tyler seems to be the most
compatible option for Hannah you know
just sort of professionally and
personally